[Musique]
oser c'est gagné
êtes vous déjà sorti une fois de votre
zone de confort avez vous déjà essayé de
repousser vos limites
est ce que la notion de dépassement de
soi ça vous parle je me présente
rémy camus je suis aventuriers
explorateur un petit peu dans la salle
peut-être vos enfants vous poser cette
question mais apparemment on fait
comment pour devenir aventurier et bien
j'ai osé
j'ai osé les choses et ce soir je vais
vous partager mes aventures avant de
commencer il faut quand même que je vous
raconte mon histoire parce que mon vrai
métier
c'est maître d'hôtel après un très long
cursus scolaire j'ai obtenu un bac
technologique en restauration
voilà ça c'est fait j'ai commencé à
voyager un petit peu partout en france
j'en ai profité pour allier le travail
avec le plaisir du tourisme mais j'étais
toujours confrontés à la même
problématique lorsqu'il avait des
clients étrangers qui venaient dans le
restaurant j'étais incapable de prendre
la commande en anglais parce que je ne
comprenais rien donc du coup j'ai osé
j'ai pris mon sac à dos et je suis parti
en angleterre dans une petite ville à
côté du sort et guilford j'étais employé
dans un établissement français
et puis j'ai rencontré un anglais
galerie nichols lors d'une soirée un
petit peu trop arrosée vraiment rose et
s'il aime bien boire des angles galerie
en fait s'est confié à moi et puis il
m'a dit rémy à ton âge j'étais déjà
parti en nouvelle zélande à l'autre bout
de la planète
cette conversation mais un petit peu
troublé si bien qu'un mois plus tard je
suis arrivé à la porte de son bureau
avec ma lettre de démission
et pourquoi je vous parle de tout ça ce
soir
et bien tout simplement parce que j'ai
osé j'ai osé les choses j'ai osé
l'aventuré j'ai osé l'inconnu j'ai osé
me dépasser donc si vous voulez bien on
va faire quelque chose ce soir
enfin cet après-midi par excusez moi on
va faire ça ensemble
à chaque fois je vais vous dire d'après
vous vous allez dire j'ai osé
d'accord on le fait ensemble d'après
vous
j'ai rien entendu ben oui recommencer
d'après vous voilà bah c'est ça en
novembre 2007
je suis parti en nouvelle zélande tu
arrives à auckland tout le monde sortait
et partez à l'arrêt de bus j'ai fait un
peu comme tout le monde je fais un petit
peu le mouton on est montés dans le bus
nous a déposés en centre ville
et puis après j'ai pris une chambre dans
une guesthouse les hôtels pour voyageurs
j'ai rencontré david de république
tchèque va discuter un petit peu tous
les deux et puis je lui demandais
c'était possible que je parte avec lui
vous voyagez m'a dit oui
cinq jours après on a acheté un camion
ensemble on a fait tout le tour d'un
nouvelle zélande n'a travaillé ensemble
dans les vergers collecter les raisins
on a fait les vendanges
j'ai passé mon premier noël en short à
christchurch
j'ai passé mon 31 décembre monde cook
village et huit mois après je suis parti
de nouvelle zélande avec les larmes aux
yeux tellement que ce pays m'avait
bouleversé je suis rentré en europe en
france puis après je retourne en
angleterre parce que j'avais retrouvé un
travail
et là j'ai rencontré une polonaise me
dit viens avec moi via en pologne
d'après vous effectivement je suis parti
en pologne bon j'ai trouvé un emploi
dans un restaurant italien
j'étais le seul français qui parlait pas
un seul mot polonais d'ailleurs les
clients à chaque fois rigoler imposer
cette question mais pourquoi est ce
qu'un français et en pologne
d'habitude c'est des polonais qui
partent et là je leur dis mais la raison
en est simple c'est parce que c'est une
polonaise et la raison était suffisante
pour eux apparemment mais bon si moi
j'ai persuadé mon ami de partir avec moi
en australie pour faire un autre clip
ensemble et donc on est partis qu'on a
intérêt à sydney on a acheté un vieux
camion aménagé et on a fait tout le tour
d'australie
on est parti sur la grande barrière de
corail
on a pu nager a été voir le lever et
coucher de soleil soit au local à tchita
ce gros monolithe rouge un plat bio
l'australie n'a vu des dauphins des
tortues on a roulé dans le bush des
lignes droites à perte de vue
au bout des neuf mois d' aventure on a
vendu notre camion et avec la vente et
l'argent du camion on est parti en asie
mais partie en thaïlande puis a su
ensuite on est partis au lard ou c'est
là où on a vu pour la première fois le
fleuve mékong et ensuite dans les
rentrer en thaïlande
on est parti de la malaisie on est
rentré en europe et après je pense qu'on
a nous avons décidé enfin en fait non
langer décidé de mettre fin à notre
relation
ce que je pense qu'on avait c'est fait
le tour ensemble vocal est retourné en
pologne
et puis moi je suis parti travailler
dans un restaurant à côté de genève à
thoiry une étoile au guide michelin et
je suis devenu maître d'hôtel on sait
pas finie vous inquiétez pas tant d un
matin d'hiver
je reçois un coup de téléphone de ma
maman qui me dit rémy j'ai un truc super
sympa pour toi tu prends des vacances si
tu viens me voir en bretagne j'ai loué
une petite maison savait vraiment sympa
effectivement donc je pars en bretagne
et le soir même je la questionne sur
notre programme de vacances et elle me
dit il ya une grande brocante demain il
ya 700 exposants faut qu'on la fasse je
dis tu m'as fait traverser
la france pour une brocante me dit oui
mais tu vas voir c'est bien
effectivement à la véraison
le lendemain je laisse pas un moment
partir et chez chine et de son côté et
moi je pars du mien je tombe sur une
femme qui vendait toute sa collection de
bouquins et je tombe sur un livre cas
complètement capter mon mon regard
dessus c'était jamel balhi un français
d'origine marocaine qui a traversé
l'amérique en courant les parti d'alaska
jusqu'à talent à del fuego ce qui
représente environ 24000 km en un an et
demi j'ai acheté le bouquin je les lui
en une nuit et le lendemain un projet
tenais je me suis dit si lui il a réussi
à faire ça mais pourquoi pas moi ça peut
être intéressant
donc du coup j'ai mûri mon projet est
d'après vous effectivement j'ai osé
j'ai mis huit mois huit mois à monter
mon projet à m'entraîner tous les jours
parce que je savais courir je savais
courir je sais vers 10 km mais il a
fallu que je fasse beaucoup plus donc
pendant huit mois je me suis entraîné à
faire 40 kilomètres par jour à monter
mon projet que ce soit au niveau
administratif obtenir les autorisations
construire un équipement adapté pour
pouvoir faire ça puis comme mon projet a
bien été ficelé
j'en ai quand même informé ma maman je
lui dis tu te rappelles le bouquin que
j'avais lu mais dit oui et bien moi
aussi je vais traverser un pays en
courant et ce sera l'australie et sa
première remarque ça a été tu aurais pas
pu choisir le luxembourg en une journée
c'était fini et on n'en parlait plus et
avait traversé un pays un juif non mais
c'est pas le même la même chose quand
même
et donc en octobre 2011
mais voilà en australie avec une
remorque fait maison pour tenter la
traversée du continent au courant de
melbourne à darwin ce qui représente à
peu près cinq mille quatre cents
kilomètres alors les buts étaient
multiples 1 le premier c'était pour moi
depuis tout à l'heure je vous parle de
osez les choses eh bien je voulais voir
si j'étais capable de me dépasser de me
surpasser d'aller de l'avant d'aller
vers l'inconnu
la deuxième chose c'était pour également
collecter des fonds et faire connaître
une maladie qui s'appelle le syndrome de
l'homme maladie génétique qui touche
principalement les garçons
et puis enfin je voulais rencontrer les
aborigènes les vrais ceux qui sont dans
les communautés perdu au milieu du bush
donc du coup à l'équipement en face et
fantastique fait maison
darbo sa tenue une journée merci papa
c'est pas mieux avant mais ça de côté et
des galères j'en ai eu
j'en ai eu beaucoup pendant mon
expédition
j'ai vu mon urine pour pas mourir d
hydrater en plein désert j'avais pas le
choix et dépecer un kangourou fait
kangourou étaient vivants juste avant
c'est que le un camion qui est passé au
même moment et qui a percuté le camp
gros donc du coup il était 9 heures du
matin
le petit déjeuner est servi c'était
parfait donc j'ai ouvert le kangourou
j'ai récupéré le sens que j'ai bu et
puis j'ai mangé la viande tout
simplement ces crues comme un tartare
c'est très bon et quand je suis reparti
en fait quelques kilomètres plus loin
une dame qui s'arrêtait en voiture qui
est sortie un peu rapidement de la
voiture un peu affolés et à me demande
tout va bien everything all right
oui oui tout va bien est en fait en ne
baissant je regarde mon tee shirt était
couvert de sang et de poils de kangourou
et je lui dis tout simplement je fais
vous inquiétez pas d'endroit ricketts
not my blog c'est pas mon sens
et en fait on allait monter à la voiture
elle est partie très rapidement et je me
suis dit à mon avis je vais avoir la
police dans peu de temps bon il s'est
rien passé je vous rassure ça a été très
rapide mais ça m'a j'ai pas pensé à ça
en fait j'ai juste bon tant pis j'ai
continué mon aventure
je suis arrivé plein milieu de
l'australie j'ai rencontré un bushman
les 11 ea on appelle et puis me dis si
tu continues la route tu vas trouver une
caravane sur le côté gauche
tu peux aller dedans tu peux dormir ça
m'appartient repose toi et une
couverture nuageuse assez importante
l'orage était imminent chalet c'est bon
je vais là-bas je vais en profiter je
rentre dans la caravane j'étais
tellement fatigué que je regarde même
pas ce qu'il ya dans la caravane je
m'allonge sur le lit et le lendemain
malheureusement je me fait mordre par
une araignée une red back pas bien gros
seins c'est gros comme ça trois
centimètres de diamètre sont un peu une
veuve noire
sauf qu'elle a la particularité d'avoir
à un petit trait rouge au niveau de
l'abdomen
j'ai cherché partout dans la caravane il
y avait partout en fait nous avez quoi
il en faut plus pour arrêter rémy
moncaut j'ai continué et continue et je
suis arrivé dans le désert
j'ai rencontré les aborigènes j'ai
rencontré un aborigène qui s'appelait
paul caubet qui me dit rémi tu vas venir
chasser avec moi fait d'accord je sais
ensemble donc du coup me dit tu viens
demain matin du monde en 4 4 et c'est
parti montant de 4,4
et puis je regarde un petit peu autour
du 4 4 et elle est où la lance je me
rappelle les aborigènes et peaux de
bêtes là lens a les boules à lens bat de
lance du coup on commence à rouler effet
d'être un fusil pour pouvoir tuer les
kangourous et au même moment il un
kangourou qui passe devant nous il
rétrograde il accélère il roule sur
kangoo effet là il est mort il lui dit
mais c'est quand même assez radical
effet faut vivre avec son temps quand
même un nom
ça a été expéditif j'ai poursuivi mon
aventure
et puis à 300 km de l'arrivée j'ai eu un
appel de ma maman parce qu'à m'appeler
tous les trois jours
quand même pour savoir si ça se passait
bien des voix s'étaient émues tout va
bien je vais me tuer ou je fais biais du
sable du désert bus et un kangourou
morts d'accord trois jours après tu es
ou du sable des arbustes mais ça change
jamais c'est tout le temps même chose
c'est malheureusement c'est toujours la
même chose et on m'appelle et me dit
j'ai entendu à la forme à nos
informations il y avait un ouragan qui
allait s'abattre sur les côtes de darwin
et je lui dis non il n'est pas il ne
s'est pas battu sur les côtes de darwin
il est là en ce moment au dessus de ma
tête et la communication s'est coupé
parce que malheureusement la couverture
nuageuse était trop importante et elle
est restée comme ça si jours sans mais
nouvelle avec l' angoisse d où est mon
fils mais je suis arrivé je suis arrivé
à barwin après mon aventure 100 jours
pour faire cinq mille quatre cents
kilomètres
ce qui m'a marqué le plus dans cette
expédition c'est le manque d'eau la soif
c'est quelque chose que je n'arriverai
pas à vous d'écrire parce qu'il faut
l'avoir vécu une fois dans sa vie pour
voir ce que c'est le manque d'eau la
soif on pourrait tuer pour avoir de
l'eau je suis revenu en france
je me suis dit c'est intéressant de
pousser sur cette thématique sur l'eau
donc du coup j'ai réfléchi à un autre
projet j'ai déjà fait quelque chose en
courant alors je me suis dit pourquoi
pas la nage va j'aime bien nager quand j
aime bien nager je savais faire 50
mètres sans couler bon je me suis dit
j'aime bien nager on va faire ça la nage
bon après vous effectivement j'ai osé
j'ai monté mon projet ça m'a pris un an
et quatre mois pour monter ce projet a
nagé de 50 mètres à 10 km par jour à
obtenir toutes les autorisations
nécessaires des visas les permis à
construire quelque chose d'adapté pour
pouvoir faire mon expédition et en
octobre 2013
j'étais debout à côté du fleuve mékong
sur la partie haute au tibet pour
pouvoir parcourir les 4400 km de ce
fleuve jusqu'à son embouchure au vietnam
à la nage et des galères j'en ai eu
vraiment je n'ai eu beaucoup je me suis
fait arrêter sur le troisième plus gros
barrage au monde
ils m'ont fait sortir à la kalachnikov
merci google traduction pour moi m'a
aidé à trouver une solution parce que je
savais pas du tout ce que je voulais
faire mon arrêté pour on va dire ça
commente tracasseries administratives a
bien phu yen la capitale du laos pendant
un mois et trois jours ils ont tous
saisis ils m'ont laissé avec une
combinaison 7 mm un gilet de sauvetage
sur le dos et mondiaux vous appellera
plus tard
merci donc heureusement qu'ils avaient
des touristes qui étaient là pour
pouvoir m'aider à avancer à ne pas
perdre la tête
j'ai continué mon aventure après j'ai
été affecté par la qualité des eaux
j'avais un pied qui était énorme je
pouvais plus chaussé mes palmes
tellement que la qualité des eaux
étaient mauvaises mais j'ai continué
dans le delta du mékong
j'ai dû combattre la marée montante et
descendante
pascal affecte le fleuve jusqu'à 300
kilomètres à l'intérieur des terres
je nageais 6 heures je dormais 6h
jeunesse de 6 heures je dormais 6 heures
mais ça si j'avais le cours du soleil un
forcément donc on hache deux jours de
nuit et j'ai réussi et le 14 avril 2014
je suis arrivé à la fin de mon
expédition six mois d'aventuré
six mois la voiture pour avoir fait 4400
km de nage des projets j'en ai d'autres
j'en ai plein d'autres j'en ai un je
voudrais partager avec vous ce soir
également
on n'en est qu'aux prémices d'un projet
qui est tout simplement la suite logique
du mékong c'est un projet
environnemental plus écologique
en fait on s'aperçoit que dans le delta
du mékong
il y a des multitudes de déchets des
quantités de déchets qui malheureusement
sont à la surface du ce de la surface de
l'eau et la plupart des déchets sont
issus de matières plastiques
on sait que la plupart du plastique sont
issus des hydrocarbures donc n'y
aurait-il pas un moyen un procédé de
retransformer ce plastique et de lui
redonner sa valeur marchande de fabas
leurs initiales le pétrole et bien si ça
s'appelle la dépolarisation donc le
projet qu'on souhaiterait mettre en
place ça serait une barge flottante avec
à son bord une machine permettant de
transformer le plastique en pétrole et
puis ça permettrait à la population
locale de d'améliorer leur habitat leur
environnement la qualité de l'eau
également mais également de créer une
économie circulaire ont grandement dans
la population locale de collecter des
déchets contre rémunération alors je
sais c'est un projet qui est difficile
quand ambitieux vous savez quoi je vais
oser je vais oser des choses c'est pas
grave je peux me planter ce n'est pas
grave mais j'aurais essayé
alors si je suis là cet après-midi pour
vous raconter toutes ces belles
histoires mais aventure mes expéditions
c'est pour vous montrer que je suis pas
si différente vous je suis exactement
comme vous j'ai juste posé les choses
j'ai osé l'aventuré osé et l'inconnu aux
et l'extrême
je voulais voir si j'étais capable de me
dépasser me surpasser vous avez tous
sans vous cette capacité de le faire au
juste la saisir alors on va faire un
truc ça peut être très sympa le dire
j'ai osé vous allez dire très fort je
vais oser s'il vous plaît dites le
exactement c'est ce qui va falloir vous
dire le jour vous avoir un nouveau
projet parce que aux et c'est gagné
merci
[Applaudissements]